j'aimerais vous en convaincre jetez vous
sur ce court roman inconnu cette longue
nouvelle de l'américaine kressmann
taylor inconnu à cette adresse et
traduite en français aux éditions
autrement
initialement paru aux états unis en 1938
ce texte limpide n'est pas sans faire
songer aux jets d'oeuvre de fred ullmann
l'ami retrouvé 50 pages d'une
intelligence et d'une intensité
rarissime 1932 voici deux amis deux
associés qui tiennent ensemble une
prospère galerie de tableaux à san
francisco l'un martin schulz eux est
allemand l'autre max eisenstein
américain est juif
le premier d'entre eux revient dans son
pays pour ouvrir à munich une succursale
de leur entreprise ils s'écrivent
régulièrement et leur lettre à l'origine
extrêmement chaleureuse constituent la
matière de ce roman au début 1933
hindenburg laisse le pouvoir à un
nouveau chancelier légalement élu le
national socialiste adolf hitler
peu à peu le ton de leur correspondance
va changer l'américain s'inquiète de ce
qu'il apprend à propos du nouveau régime
de berlin l'allemand lui adhèrent aux
idées de celui ci la distance
la méfiance la haine bientôt s'installe
entre ses esprit cultivé que la grande
histoire va opposer la fin du récit
d'une subtilité vraiment prodigieuse je
vous la laisse découvrir
vous aussi vous allez être ébloui par un
inconnu à cette adresse